I have to get to the truth of what
happened that night
I am for truth no matter who tells it
I'm for justice no matter who it's for
or against 18 years ten months twenty
four days that's how long
Warren cave has sat in prison for the
murder of Jeff Berman I helped seal
Warren's fate with a series of articles
but is there an innocent man in prison
and did I need that charge
[Music]
portrayed me as a privileged psychopath
now I live in a house for a man Oh
breathe to lie and I could smell yours
before you even started talking
how could a mother and two daughters
sleep through such a violent encounter
yeah they never recovered the murder
weapon my new ID is even or I can make
your life miserable in here there is a
monster inside every one of us you
terrified me what about you
what's in there we're playing with
people's lives are you ready for the
consequences you think all the secrets
cannot turn the track you tell Parnell
back away you messed with a family you
have no idea what I've done with my
daughter's babies they take care of each
other
[Music]
I have to get to the truth of what
happened that night
people get their show
[Music]
you